mars sonde explodiert auf dem roten
planeten es gibt neues zur exomars
mission jetzt nicht um science-fiction
am 19
oktober 2016 um 16 47 hätte es so weit
sein sollen ein europäisch russische
meilenstein in der raumfahrt sollte
erreicht werden dass es leider nicht
eingetreten
die mission mit dem ziel die erste
europäische russische lande sondern auf
dem mars landen zu lassen scheint alles
andere als planmäßig abgelaufen zu sein
im zuge der exomars mission sollte sie
sonders japan rallye am späten
nachmittag des 19
oktober sanft auf dem roten planeten
aufsetzen
begonnen hatte die mission der
europäischen weltraumagentur esa und der
russischen weltraumbehörde roskosmos im
märz 2016 unter dem namen exomars am 14
märz um 10 uhr 30 rupp die proton rakete
die den spuren gas orbiter tgo und die
sonde tabarelli geladen hatte vom
weltraumbahnhof baikonur in kasachstan
ab und sollte damit auch ein erster
schritt einer 2018 geplanten mars rover
mission sein
diese geplante mission wird allerdings
noch etwas auf ihren startschuss warten
müssen als die fracht der proton rakete
am 19 oktober 2016 auf dem mars landen
sollte meldete die esa zunächst
folgendes der 577 kilogramm schwere idm
war am 16 oktober um 1642
mitteleuropäischer zeit vom tgo
ausgesetzt worden
er war für die eigenständige
durchführung einer automatisierten lande
sequenz mit der entfaltung eines
fallschirms und der abtrennung des
hitzeschilds in einer höhe zwischen 11
und 7 kilometer über der mars oberfläche
gefolgt von einer brems raketen zündung
in einer entfernung von 1100 meter vom
boden und schließlich einem durch eine
klare struktur gepolsterten fall aus
einer höhe von zwei metern programmiert
worden
zitat ende idm steht übrigens für
entweder cent and landing demonstrator
module also eintritts abstiegs und lande
demonstrate und bezeichnet hier die
lande sondern japan rallye zu diesem
zeitpunkt wussten die experten der esa
zwar schon dass sie den kontakt zur
sonde verloren hatten aber was genau
passiert war
das wussten sie nicht dass bestand noch
hoffnung dass die mission doch noch
nicht gescheitert
einen tag später saß allerdings schon
ganz anders aus die hoffnung auf eine
fortführung der mission musste endgültig
aufgegeben werden zitat in bezug auf das
testmodul japan rallye haben uns daten
erreicht mit denen wir den gesamten
ablauf nachvollziehen können und die uns
hinweise darauf liefern werden warum
keine sanfte landung erfolgte berichtete
david parker von der esa der gepolsterte
fall aus zwei kilometern habe sich neuen
erkenntnissen zur folge mit einer
geschwindigkeit von rund 300 kilometern
pro stunde viel zu schnell vollzogen
die sonde soll auf der
planetenoberfläche fläche zerschellt
seien bilder der highlights kamera an
bord des mars reconnaissance orbiter sam
r zeigen vermutlich die einschlagstelle
sowie den lande fallschirm die esa
sprach dann auch selbst von einem
absturz und sogar von einer möglichen
explosion in der pressemitteilung vom 21
oktober heißt es zitat es wird geschätzt
dass cher barelli aus einer höhe von
zwischen zwei und vier kilometern
gefallen ist und somit mit einer
geschwindigkeit von mehr als 300
kilometern pro stunde aufgeschlagen ist
das relativ große merkmal könnte daher
von aufgewirbelten bodenmaterial stammen
es ist auch möglich dass das landegerät
beim aufprall explodiert ist da die
treibstofftanks wahrscheinlich noch
gefüllt waren
diese vorläufige interpretationen werden
durch weitere zukünftige analysen
ergänzt zitat ende ist der traum von
einer ersten europäische russischen
lande sondern auf dem mars also wir
sehen jetzt vorbei vor wenigen tagen
traf ein neues bild in der bodenstation
ein auf der aufnahme ist klar zu
erkennen die sonde ist hinüber und das
offenbar aufgrund eines kuriosen
vorfalls zitat die navigations-software
sind navi software hat gedacht die
landung wäre bereits vollzogen dann
haben die bremse geht nur noch die
minimal vorgewählte zeit von etwa drei
sekunden gefeuert so rolf densing von
der esa in darmstadt jetzt bleibt den
forschern tatsächlich erstmal nur noch
der ttg aber da gehen sie davon aus dass
sie ja ohne ende
neue ergebnisse neue erkenntnisse
gewinnen wenn euch das video gefallen
hat dann lass mir gerne einen daumen
nach oben und
kostenloses abo da einfach hier klicken
und wenn er hier klickt kommt ihr zu
einem video in dem wir uns mit einer
anderen sehr spannenden mars-mission
beschäftigen was glaubt ihr sollen die
europäer jetzt die erforschung des mars
aufgeben schreibt mir eure meinung dazu
und wenn es neue erkenntnisse darüber
gibt dann gerne in die kommentare und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran